remember last year when joe biden and
kamal harris were obsessed with the law
no one is above the law including the
president of the united states our
president is not above the law
what we do want is a justice system
where no one is above the law not even
the president of the united states he's
shooting holes in the constitution
and we can not let him get away with it
well it turns out no one is above the
law
except hunter who continues to live his
best life painting away in nantucket
with the big guy despite more
revelations from the laptop from hell we
now know that the communist chinese used
hunter biden to help with high class
business introductions for chinese
communist party linked energy company
one of the largest energy companies in
the world and a direct arm of the ccp
in exchange for his services hunter was
reportedly rewarded 10 million dollars a
year
and a shiny 80 000 diamond on top
all of this for knowingly introducing
top chinese communists to top u.s
officials so that china could get an
upper hand on the u.s economy and u.s
energy it's all right there in the
laptop from hell wait for miranda
devine's book hunter's daddy was vice
president both of them were making money
off of the communists do you think
you're going to hear about this on cnn
or msnbc
probably not it doesn't fit their
narrative so of course they'll ignore it
hear now author of do what you say you
would do congressman jim jordan and buck
sexton co-host of the clay travis and
buck sexton show gentlemen bo thanks for
being here you were front and center for
a congressman the absolute obsession
with russia which turned out to be false
now you've got the absolute suppression
of biden and china which now we're
learning is true
yeah well my big takeaway is the bidens
just think they're better than us better
than us regular folks who live here and
fly over contouring i mean you know last
week joe biden's in nantucket uh staying
at a billionaire's house going to a
store without a mass last year we knew
that hunter biden took one million from
the ukrainian energy company three
million from a russian billionaire and
four million with a company with ties to
the chinese communist party and now we
learn what you just described so they
think they're better than us the
american people get it though and
they're not going to stand for it in the
next election how do they get away buck
with that mindset i mean when you're
working with a chinese company that you
know is an extension of the chinese
comedies party you know is looking to
supplant and surpass the united states
and you're helping them do so
well theoretically pete we're supposed
to have these people called journalists
in america and they are the guardians of
our republic allegedly by providing the
public with necessary information but
when it comes to democrats selling
influence uh peddling access to office
and just straight up corruption there's
so much less interest all of a sudden
look the clintons created a global grift
scheme through what was supposed to be a
charity and got away with the tune of
tens of millions hundreds of millions of
dollars hunter biden selling paintings
for 50 to 500 000 a pop having meetings
with senior chinese communist party
officials and promising access to the
top policy makers in this country that's
just the price of doing business for
democrats i guess they don't care if any
of the trump kids did this pete you know
cnn and msnbc would cover it like the
bombing of pearl harbor but that's not
happening
you know they would congress could a
future republican majority do anything
about this
oh we're gonna we're gonna have
investigations for sure we have subpoena
power if we win back the majority and we
can call in the witnesses and get the
documents but buck's exactly right pete
remember what we knew 13 months ago
before the presidential election we had
an eyewitness tony babalinsky we had
actual physical evidence we had the
emails and the laptop and we knew that
the fbi had them under investigation but
50 people from the intelligence
community told us all it was russian
disinformation what a joke that was we
needed some real journalism about 13
months ago hey buck you've worked in the
cia would this would this be the
definition of being compromised or not
being able to do your job properly
well it certainly would be close and
continuing access it would be a
situation where you'd wonder how far
this good obviously hunter biden is not
going to be an elected office we think
anytime soon but hunter biden being this
close to people that are that seen in
the chinese communist party and trying
to pedal influence very concerning
considering who's really running the
country right now anyway that's right
and who else has hundred been talking to
yeah and if you consider 10 for the big
guy you know who knows where it goes two
smart dudes here jim jordan buck sexton
thank you so much appreciate your time
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else